طبعا الجموع الجمهور السعودي بدا بالتوافد
من امس عبر الطائرات وايضا عبر منفذ سلوى
بالحافلات هناك تسهيلات كبيره للجماهير
السعوديه تقوم بها وزاره الرياضه وجميع
الجهات الحكوميه السعوديه بالتعاون مع
اللجنه المنظمه في همم قطر همم سيكون هناك
امس بالامس شاهدنا التجمع في تجرب الوسيل
وتحفيز وتواجد جماهير الكبير للجمهور
السعودي اليوم سيكون هناك مسيره تبدا
الساعه السادسه مساءا وسنكون متواجدين
باذن الله هناك ستبدا المسيره الساعه
السادسه مساءا على الاقدام لمده نصف ساعه
حتى الوصول الى المنطقه القريبه همم من
الملعب سيستشهد الاف الجماهير السعوديه في
ما يخص التذاكر هناك يعني طلب كبير على
همم التذاكر همم بالامس همم طاح مجلس
الجمهور السعودي ثلاثه الاف تذكره وتم
بيعها همم بشكل مباشر يعني في اصدقائك
بيعه اكثر من 3000 تذكره فيفا قامت بطمح
تذاكر مساء امس وبيعت بالكامل وقبل ساعتين
تقريبا فيفا ايضا طرح تذاكر فيفا يقوم
بالتاكد من من صاحب التذكره في حال عدم
حضوره الى قطر او اصدار همم بطاقه همم هيا
هو يقوم باعاده طرح مره اخرى حتى يضمن
امتلاء الملاعب نعلم ان الوسيل همم 88,000
متفرج همم الجماهير السعوديه ستكون لها
الغالبيه همم العظمى وهي تفوق همم
الجماهير المكسيكيه بشكل كبير ايضا هناك
تيفو هناك استعدادات همم سيرتدي الجمهور
السعودي القميص الابيض حتى يكون مثل
المنتخب السعودي الذي سيرتدي اليوم الخميس
الابيض داخل الارضيه الملعب